ja was haben wir heute vor heute geht es
um unseren ersten großen philosophen und
sagen der wahrheit' theorie im platow
aber bevor wir beginnen wollte ich noch
kurz der liste durchgehen da sind für
diejenigen die noch nicht angemeldet
sind wir nach melden wollen
ich bitte auch nochmal jeden mehr die
ganz genaue studiengangs kombination zu
schreiben weil für das nach melden
mehrere möglichkeiten gegeben sind das
ist einfach falls sie noch nicht
angemeldet sind das noch mal ein tragen
auch mit der studien kombination so
bevor wir jetzt direkt in den text
einsteigen hat jeder von ihnen eine
e-mail bekommen von mir eine
zusammenfassung der ersten sitzung die
texte falls nicht schreiben sie mir
einfach noch mal eine e mail
für diejenigen die neu hinzugestoßen
sind möchte ich auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen wir haben hier digitale
begleitende angebote einmal das dicke
seminar und einmal philo cast und jetzt
würde ich sagen zu beginn zum einstieg
machen wir mal hier
die app sage ich auch noch mal kurz also
sie haben bestimmt schon mitbekommen es
gibt der begleitmaterialien machen wir
mal einen wahrheitsgemäß zu beginn sie
haben vielleicht gesehen wenn es jetzt
hier auf die lowcost gehen dann finden
sie hier
ein wahrheit' quiz und das starten jetzt
einfach mal anschauen was passiert ob
das funktioniert hier ja
kann man sehen
na also kreuzen sie eine oder mehrere
zutreffende antworten ja wobei handelt
es sich um klassische wahrheit' theorie
relativitätstheorie bbq renz theorie
theologischer theorie die korrespondenz
theorie
bitte was sie dürfen einfach ihre
meinungen hier per zuruf kundtun
ja
berta und dora gibt es andere ansichten
ist es richtig was der kommilitone sagt
dann versuchen wir mal ob das klappt ja
es ist richtig so zur nächsten frage
das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig
weil es vielleicht nicht ganz klar
formuliert ist ich habe einen kollegen
diese frage auch vorgelegt und er hat
gesagt also muss man völlig anders
formulieren
vielleicht verstehen sie das was ich
gemeint habe also was kann war es seien
alle sätze alle urteile aller dinge alle
proposition ja
ja ja gut ich schreibe jetzt im einsatz
hin und dann können sie kurz darüber
diskutieren ob der satz war sein kann
so ist heute dienstag
genau fragen mit fragen ist es schwierig
haben sie die intuition warum kann die
frage mich heute falsch sein was würden
sie sagen wichtig
genaue position ist noch klären was ist
denn eine proposition wer von ihnen weiß
dass eine proposition da ist eine
meldung ja genau also aussage satz und
das ist kein aussage satz das ist eine
frage wenn ich jetzt schreibe heute ist
dienstag
ich kann das zum beispiel auch mit einem
ausrufezeichen versehen das würde nichts
daran ändern es würde sogar noch eher
den charakter einer proposition oder
einer these thesen könnte ich jetzt auch
noch mit rein nehmen können luthers 95
thesen reformationsjubiläum können auch
mal falsch sein
heute ist dienstag ja das ist eine
position also alles was sie in so eine
das form bringen können punkt punkt
punkt komma das und dann können sie
irgendwas einsetzen also behaupten dass
die these vertreten dass argumentieren
dass alles was sich ein solcher das form
bringen das heute dienstag ist dass die
erde sich um die sonne dreht dass die
sonne sich um die erde dreht sind alles
proposition die wada falsch sein könnte
wie wäre es denn wenn ich jetzt diesen
satz hier morgen hin geschrieben hätte
er ist dann falsch aber er ist wahrheit
fertig hat war er kann wahrheit' werte
annehmen
erst war heizwert fähig ist eine entität
als ein ding raus das existiert das wahr
oder falsch sein kann
und bei der frage ob heute dienstag ist
da kann man eben kein war heizwert
vergeben wir haben uns setzt einmal
gefragt gibt es immer nur zwei drei
heitz werte wahr oder falsch oder gibt
es noch einen dritten unentschieden oder
vielleicht noch einen vierten
also wir werden uns hier in diesem
seminar eigentlich nur mit wahr oder
falsch mit dieser binären opposition
beschäftigen ja also setzte
offensichtlich nicht weil es gibt fragen
je nachdem wie man es versteht in der
mathematik ist es auch was ganz anderes
als jetzt in der allgäuer umgangssprache
in alltagssprache ja warum warum ich
jetzt nicht dinge wie ist es damit dass
ein bisschen schwieriger her was machen
könnten auch dinge wahr sein überlegen
sie mal in welchem zusammenhang sprechen
wir von dingen so dass sie war genannt
werden vielleicht erinnern sie sich noch
ich habe doch bitte hier
[Musik]
guter punkt haben sie so eine wendung wo
man manchmal von dingen im sinne von war
spricht oder vielleicht echt
genau aber das ist richtig sind auch das
urteilende das urteil wäre dann darüber
dass es ein echter picasso genau das
bild schwierig schwierig oder haben sie
noch nicht
genau also zum beispiel ein echter
picasso dann denken sie mal an gold das
ist echtes gold oder ist es nur kupfer
auch da ist natürlich die frage unseres
zugangs letztendlich diejenigen die über
wahrheiten falschheit entscheiden und
nicht so sehr das ding
denken sie mal ganz kurz noch an einen
falschen menschen an einen wahrhaftigen
menschen einen falschen menschen wie ist
es denn da ist es da auch unser urteil
das nur betroffen ist oder ist es da
nicht doch ein bisschen und logischer
also mehr in der sache selbst begründet
aber es wäre dann ja nicht unser urteil
über den menschen so süß und der mensch
der häufig wahre urteile von sich gibt
oder häufig falsche mit absicht könnte
man sagen also ich glaube wenn wenn wenn
wir über personen entsprechende für
lebewesen also freie subjekte die sich
entscheiden können ob sie die wahrheit
sagen und nicht dann haben wir glaube
ich eine möglichkeit sein und
theologischen wahrheit' begriff zu
verwenden
es gibt auch im mittelalter und
theologische wahrheit' begriffe die das
waren falschen der sache sehen erscheint
wenn man so sagen das ist ein
wahrhaftiger mensch der ist aufrichtig
sagt die wahrheit oder eine der er
täuscht er häufig täuscht dann scheint
mir dass ihr treffen dazu sagen aber
solche begriffe spielen hier in diesem
seminar nicht so eine rolle
jetzt hatten sie sich ganz sind erst
noch gewinnen kann si
ja also sehen wir die frage was ist
wahrhaftig aber wenn man es jetzt ganz
ganz banal nimmt einfach nur ein mensch
der die dinge so band nennt oder so
solche urteile äußert die mit der
wirklichkeit überein springen stimmt
also korrespondenz theorie wenn das
überhaupt sowas gibt das problem ist
natürlich im menschen anwesen zu
unterstellen dass der mensch immer die
wahrheit sagte die falschheit gesagt das
ist schon sehr problematisch so etwas zu
machen weil es wahrscheinlich kein
menschen gibt ja immer nur die wahrheit
sagt habe ich glaube schon dass nine
wenn es das gäbe wenn es menschen gebe
die immer nur die wahrheit oder nur die
falschheit sagen alles absicht dass man
schon sagen könnte das ist ein
wahrhaftiger mich natürlich ist damit
nicht der mensch betroffen ein wahrer
mensch hat ein falscher mensch also ist
ein mensch natürlich aber wir sind
dieser wahrhaftigkeit ich habe es
genannt diesen diese authentizität
theoretische theorie der wahrheit könnte
man das zu machen aber nur abgeleiteten
sind jetzt noch einen geben uns nächsten
vereinbar
ja völlig richtig also der wahrheit'
begriff ist etwas vage wir haben andere
begriffe die damit eng verwandt sind wie
authentizität echtheit ehrlichkeit
überprüfbarkeit genau wir wollen hier in
recht engen begriff von wahrheit
zugrunde liegen legen und deswegen
kommen in erster linie urteilen position
infrage
mit den dingen mit der unter logi der
wahrheit müssen wir noch schauen wir
werden es damit auch zu tun haben
jetzt gehe ich mal zur nächsten frage
also wenn jetzt keine einwände sind
klicke ich hier auf senden richtig so
jetzt kommt die nächste frage worin
besteht das
worin besteht das problem einer kohärenz
theorie der wahrheit
die karosserie erlaubt logische
widersprüche die differenz terry erlaubt
entgegengesetzte korinther theorien die
karenz theorie ist nicht an der
wirklichkeit geerdet die die corinths
theorie ist theologisch was kommt ein
frage ganz hinten ja ja und cesar andere
ergänzende meinungen widersprüche ist
das falsch was der kommilitone sagt ist
das wahr was der komponist sagt
[Musik]
ich weiß selbst auch gerade nicht mehr
als wir müssen das ausspricht was ich
werde überlegt habe ich weiß ja
[Musik]
eine gute frage
genau dass man sagt also wenn wir zwei
mögliche rente theorien eines
gegenstandes haben dann haben wir
vielleicht den gegenstand nicht genug
vor ort im größeren kontext müssen immer
solis muss nennt man das also ich halte
es gibt auch holistische wahrheit'
begriffe bedeutet das ganze wallis muss
ist also eine ausrichtung auf das ganze
holz griechisch das ganze also ob es
eine theorie des ganzen gibt eine
bäuerin story all dessen was existiert
die noch eine konträre vielleicht sogar
eine kontradiktorische ist die frage wo
rente theorie derselben ganzen zulässt
oder nicht das ist die frage
richtig also wahrheit wird gemäß der
chor in stereo als chor in das gefüge
bestimmt dasjenige ist war ein system
von setzen ist war eine theorie ist wahr
wenn ihre sätze auf eine ganz besondere
art und weise gefüllt sind wenn die
theorie ein eine struktur hat die in
sich geschlossen ist und wo jeder satz
den anderen gegenseitig stützt
so kann man sich das vorstellen wo die
prämissen in einer beziehung zueinander
stehen die nicht willkürlich sein sollen
die sich gegenseitig erhellen weiter
begründen uns ein dichtes begründung
systemen steht ganz verschiedene
begründung verhältnisse die sich
gegenseitig stützen und als ganzes die
wahrheit aufrichten so muss man sich die
karenz theorie fisch vorstellen
und da ist natürlich noch keine
tautologie drin weil wir sagen wahrheit
ist krems haben wir keine tautologie
sagen wenn ich dasselbe nochmal dann
beginnen wir kein zurückgestoßen
letztendlich wir setzen da nichts heraus
was wir wir wollen nicht durch wir
wollen etwas erklären was sie bereits
voraussetzen wahrheit in karenz sind
jetzt endlich semantisch gesehen nicht
aufeinander reduzierbar insofern ist es
ein informatives urteil windel sagen war
ist das was korrekt ist eine tautologie
ist nicht so wie alle junggesellen sind
unverheiratet das im begriff schon das
prädikat schon im subjekt enthalten ist
wie unverheiratet in junggeselle das ist
bei kohärenz und wahrheit die mir
scheint nicht der fall
jetzt klicken einfach mal auf senden ob
das richtig ist es ist richtig also wie
gesagt richtig dann müssen sie immer mit
bedacht das sehen man kann das natürlich
immer noch in frage stellen wie der
kommilitone sitzt gemacht hat aber so
nach dem was in den letzten sitzung
gesprochen hat müsste das stimmen
kann man wahrheit definieren
nein dieser versuch ist sehr cool er b
nein denn in wahrheit definieren zu
müssen zu definieren müssen wir
wahrheit' bereits voraussetzen zehn
jahren wahrheit ist ein transfer thaler
begriff den ein den weit ist ein
transplantat begriff
die augen
als auch technologien oder begriffs
analyse sind informativ könnte man sagen
wenn ich erkläre was ein junggeselle ist
kann das schon informativ sein wenn ich
sage dass unverheiratet jemand der noch
nicht genau also je nachdem wie man
definition versteht sie merken es wenn
man es sehr streng versteht dann scheint
eben definition wahrheit schon
vorauszusetzen ja wenn wir das zirkuläre
wollen auch dieses problem hinweisen
dass man hier unter umständen zirkel
gerät also auch das ist richtig haben
wir noch eine frage hier vielleicht nur
eine letzte nein
und wir haben mit hundertprozentiger
genauigkeit dieses quiz absolviert also
sie können das quiz gerne dass bis zur
nächsten sitzung gerne zu hause
probieren sie finden dass hier alles auf
diesen zwei seiten philo cast und die
seminare finden sie auch noch die die
zusammenfassung zur letzten sitzung
können sie hier draufklicken dann sehen
sie hier schon dass hier ein kleines
wiki system entstanden ist wenn ich hier
auf wahrheit clique komme ich hier auf
einen anderen artikel und der wird
natürlich immer noch ergänzt und sohn
also sie können gerne auch mit schreiben
oder wenn sie jetzt sagen ich habe eine
frage dazu zu dem eintrag dann gehen sie
einfach hierhin und gehen sie darunter
und tragen denn hier ein kommentar
eigentlich einfach irgendwie das habe
ich nicht verstanden oder das müssen sie
noch ergänzen geben ihren namen ein e
mail element wird nicht angezeigt aber
man muss es halt machen
damit es kein sam ist und dann kann ich
das veröffentlichen dann können wir hier
auch noch nach dem seminar darüber
diskutieren so aber jetzt genug der vor
überlegungen jetzt kommen wir zu platon
und sie haben vielleicht gesehen der e
mail ich mache das immer so dass ich
einige leitfragen vorher an sie
versenden
wir haben hier ein paar leitfragen für
die heutige sitzung also zuerst welche
wahrheit' theorie vertritt platon von
denen die wir kennen
handelt es sich um eine korrespondenz
oder eine kohärenz theorie oder um etwas
ganz anderes
dann inwiefern ist seine wahrheit'
theorie problematisch das muss natürlich
auch überlegen
also wir wollen hier noch nicht ja nur
leider weniger nachbeten was die
philosophen uns zu sagen haben oder
gesagt haben soll wir wollen uns immer
fragen gibt es dagegen einwände gegen
eine solche auffassung verlangen dass
wir wollen ja nicht nur para passieren
wir wollen ja aktiv mit philosophieren
so das ist diese diese frage und jetzt
habe ich hier drei gleichnisse
ausgewählt von platon sie kennen die
sicherlich alle schon mal gehört das
höhlengleichnis das sonnen gleichen es
dass linie gleichnis wir beginnen mit
dem höhengleichen ich habe hier also ein
paar zitate ausgewählt die werfe ich
jetzt gleich an die tafel und dann
können wir einfach mal der reise ein
bisschen vorlesen man erstmal jeder ein
zitat nimmt und dann haben wir den text
hier präsent und kindern darüber
diskutieren also erhalten sie diese
leitfragen im hinterkopf welche wahrheit
theorie vertritt platte dieses kohärenz
theorie ist es korrespondenz theorie ist
es eine ganz andere theorie und wenn es
eine ganz andere theorie ist wie müsste
man die dann nennen welchen begriff
müsste man dafür prägen
und wenn es eine andere theorie ist
inwiefern ist sie problematisch
inwiefern ist überzeugend dass wir uns
mal frage so da beginnen wir doch
einfach hier mal in dieser ersten den
ersten zitat des höhengleichen scannen
sie das ist also ganz bekannt da geht es
um eine veranschaulichung eine bildliche
metaphorische vielleicht sogar alle
chorische veranschaulichung unserer
existenz der existenz von endlichen
wesen wie wir sind von menschen und
platin möchte bildlich allegorisch
zeigen wie wir menschen endlich fließen
zur erkenntnis kommen und erkenntnis
heißt natürlich immer erkenntnis dass
waren das richtige nicht das falsch
jetzt wollen wir uns fragen wie platon
diese erkenntnis möglichkeit des
menschen bildlich wand schauen und in
dieser metaphorik der verbindet dieser
metaphorik sehen wir was von wahrheit'
begriffe hat achten sie jetzt einfach
mal ein bisschen im folgenden auf die
wahl der metaphern den bildbereich den
platten verwendet um sein wals theorie
näher zu erläutern
jetzt beginnen wir doch einfach mal
wollen sie gerade noch vorlesen geht es
ja
gestanden sich menschen einer
unterirdischen leistung die allerdings
nicht zusammen
genau wie kann man sich das jetzt
vorstellen ich habe da jetzt mal so eine
grafik hier die bin ich mal ganz kurz
hier so sieht es ungefähr außen können
sie das einigermaßen sehen die sonne ist
zu stark wir haben zu viel wahrheit
heute in diesem raum
aber wir müssen froh sein weil wir uns
nicht in dieser höhle befinden
die sonne ist hier wirklich präsent also
wir haben hier die grundsituation das
ist das was jetzt vorgelesen haben diese
szenerie hier ich weiß nicht was genau
erkennen kann hier diese menschen die
hier so mauer sind die seen jetzt hier
solche schattenbilder von gegenständen
hinter der mauer die wiederum von dem
feuer bewirkt werden diese
schattenbilder online gibt es hier aber
auch noch ein echtes von hier oben da wo
wahrheit steht hier das ist szenario
erst einmal geht wieder noch ein
bisschen zurück lesung einfach mal das
nächste zitat so die sagen das nächste
vielleicht mal von hinten können sie
sind besser lesen wollen sie vielleicht
mal vater
also was denken jetzt diese menschen die
da jetzt gefesselt sind was denken sie
was die wahrheit sei genau und wir als
betrachter die wir die ganze szenerie
kennen wir wissen natürlich dass das nur
schattenbilder sind also nur schein ist
das ist nicht das war ist ganz klar und
sie vielleicht das nichts zu lesen
auch zu stehen
unsere lieben dich zu sehen
die bilanz ist nicht schlechter möchte
die den siegeszug von dem stoff ist was
man geboten würde jetzt sagen
damals habe er jetzt aber dem zeigen in
der nun zu den ersten die wende sehr
wichtiges und übergeben zeigen
instruktoren strecke das zeige dass für
mich die ganze zeit im glauben oder darf
es nicht sehen dann auch wirklich als
und jetzt gezeigt werde
da war einmal
vielen dank also es ist klar wohin das
ganze führt jetzt kann man natürlich
sich vorstellen dass diese leute sich
umdrehen und dieses licht sehen dieses
feuer was wir wollen auf dieser grafik
auch hatten
dann würden sie natürlich erkennen dass
das nur schatten sind und sie würden
dieses feuer für wirklich sein da halten
als die schatten
wie wäre es denn das verhältnis von
feuer und schatten bilden sie das mal
beschreiben was für ein verhältnis ist
das feuer und schatten auf der einen
seite genau wie kann man das noch ein
bisschen mehr was hängt von dem ab genau
genau so kann man es beschreiben könnte
man es noch beschreiben wenn sie mal
denken was genau so kann man es sehen
also die das feuer ist die bedingung der
möglichkeit also die bedingungen dafür
das ist bedingt die schatten und man
könnte auch noch her
ein guter gedanke weil man könnte ja
sagen das feuer kann unendlich viele
gegenstände schattieren oder zu schatten
bildern werden lassen und die menschen
die dort gefesselt sind die sehen nur
eine ganz geringe anzahl von scharfen
bildern also das feuer hat vielmehr
möglichkeit als es die tatsächlich
schatten sind genau könnte auch noch
sagen das feuer ist der kausale grund
das feuer ist ursächlich ist nicht ob
die bedingungen jetzt im weitesten sinne
es ist das die ursache der kausale grund
für diese show natürlich völlig richtig
was sie gesagt haben diese gegenstände
die vor das feuer gehalten werden und
zwischen die wand dies sind unter
umständen dreidimensional und was
passiert durch das feuer man sieht es
nur noch zweidimensional
also es geht ganz wichtiger aspekt der
dinge verloren
richtig richtig es ist noch relativ
gesehen
das geht noch weiter es ist noch nicht
der ende das ende der ganzen tour
also das ist jetzt schon mal so eine
erste struktur die wichtig ist und jetzt
lesen wir weiter ich lese vielleicht mal
ist vielleicht ein bisschen schlecht zu
sehen und sprach ich bin in einer mit
gewalt von dort durch den unwegsamen und
steilen aufgang schleppte und nicht los
lese bis ihn das licht der sonne
gebracht hätte wird er nicht viel
schmerzen haben und sich gar ungern
schleppen lassen
also jetzt da hochschleppen ans
tageslicht und wenn er nun an das nicht
kommt und die augen voll strahlen hat
wird er nicht sehen können von dem was
ihm nun für das wahre gegeben wird
freilich nicht sagt er wenigstens
zugleich nicht gewöhnung also meine ich
wird er nötig haben und das obere zu
sehen und zuerst würde eher schatten am
leichtesten erkennen als jetzt schatten
auf der oberwelt er nach die bilder der
menschen und der anderen dinge im wasser
und dann erst sie selbst die dinge oben
ebenso was am himmel ist und den himmel
selbst würde am liebsten in der nacht
betrachten und in das mond und sternen
licht sehen als bei tage in die sonne
und ihr licht
ich sollte ja nicht zuletzt aber denke
ich wird er auch die sonne selbst nicht
bilder von ihrem wasser oder anderen
wert sondern sich selbst an ihre eigenen
stelle anzusehen und zu betrachten
imstande seien notwendig sagte und dann
wird er schon herausbringen von ihr dass
sie es ist die alle zeiten und jahre
schafft und alles ordnet in dem
sichtbaren raum und auch von dem was sie
dort sahen gewissermaßen die ursache ist
offenbar sagte er würde er nach jenem
auch hier zu kommen
also jetzt können sie mir überlegen
warum das ganze das höhlengleichnis
heißt es gibt auch ein sonnen gleichnis
warum ist es ein gleichnis was wird da
verglichen vielleicht müssen wir noch
das nächste zitat lesen geht es andere
vor wenn ein solcher nun wieder hinunter
stiegen
und sich auf denselben schädel setzten
würde ihm würden ihm die augen nicht
ganz voll dunkelheit sein der so
plötzlich von der sonne her kommt ganz
gewiss sagt er anderen
und wenn er wieder in der begutachtung
jena schatten wetteifern sollte mit
jenen mit denen die immer dort gefangen
gewesen während sieben noch vor augen
flimmert er sie wieder dazu einrichtet
und das möchte keine kleine zeit seines
aufenthalts dauern würde man ihn nicht
auslachen und von ihm sagen ihr seid mit
verdorbenen augen von oben zu bekommen
und es lohne nicht dass man versuche
hinauf zu kommen sondern müsse jeden der
sie lösen hinauf bringen wollte wenn man
seine nur habhaft werden und ihn
umbringen könnte auch wirklich umbringen
wie kann man jetzt diese sehr ist man
sich nicht ganz eindeutige rede
verstehen es ist eine gleichen schaffte
rede was wird jetzt hier im gleichnis
miteinander verbunden
menschen
genau haben sie eine idee ist sie hatten
sie reden jetzt über naturwissenschaften
hier unten ist die rede von umbringen
haben sie da ein beispiel aus der
naturwissenschaftliche erkenntnis und
demjenigen der das licht gesehen hat
auch die tour genau galileo galilei
solche ketzerischen ansichten ist
vielleicht nicht ganz in jeder hinsicht
dieselbe analogie aber auf jeden fall
dieser hinsicht derjenige der da eine
neue erkenntnis hat und er diese
erkenntnis verkündet die welt bringt der
hat es nicht mehr leicht direkt an und
er muss unter umständen im leben dafür
bezahlen das war jene meldungen
also hochzusteigen die höhle
hochzusteigen genau raus aus dem system
raus aus der gefangenschaft als sie
sehen hier schon
es kommt jetzt ein weiter begriff ins
spiel nämlich der begriff der freiheit
also wir haben jetzt ganz verschiedene
begriffe jetzt hatten sie noch gemeldet
genau also hat ganz verschiedene bezüge
und wir müssen vielleicht ein bisschen
weiter lesen noch weil das
höhlengleichnis nur eine beschreibung
ist und es wird noch ergänzt ich habe
die meldung alle gemerkt wir müssen noch
kurz auf der sonnen gleichnis übergehen
und haben sie noch gerade was dazu da
war noch zwei meldung erst 10 dann zieht
gute frage genau ganz zentrale frage wir
müssen jetzt mal schauen hier wenn ihn
also denjenigen der da sitzt einer hier
einer mit gewalt schleppt sie haben
völlig richtige wichtigen punkt
getroffen es ist nicht so dass der sich
da einfach los macht wenn die fesseln
waren locker oder hat irgendwie trick so
james bond oder irgendwie sowas mit
gelber oder so irgendwie die
handschellen die so gelöst oder so sind
da kommt jemand anderes
und der macht ihn frei und der befreiten
auch nicht irgendwie so jetzt bist du
frei wo alles wunderbar sondern achten
sie mal darauf wie das beschrieben wird
der schleppt den dort er lässt ihn nicht
los also der tut ihm fast schon gewaltig
weil der fühlt sich ja sowohl vor dieser
schattenwand da hat sich dann bequem
eingerichtet
ich habe mal bei einem philosophen im
seminar besucht in münchen
er hat gesagt das ist wie im kino wie im
kino besitzen vor der leinwand eine
wunderschöne scheinwelt die fenster
flimmert da wollen wir gar nicht mehr
raus gehen da flüchten wir uns in dieser
scheinwelt wenn dann jemand kommt sagt
jetzt aufstehen auf wir müssen da noch
was anderes machen dann würde man sich
demnächst wieder setzen also ein guter
punkt derjenige der die schattenbilder
sieht und die schattenbilder stehen
natürlich für die falschheit es ist klar
der kommt nicht von selbst auf die idee
sein ort zu verlassen weil es so bequem
ist wie im kinosessel könnte man sagen
sondern muss von jemand anderem fast
schon gewaltsam jedenfalls von außen
geführt werden und der kommilitone hatte
schon gesagt sokrates ist eine wichtige
person also das scheint auch so krist im
hintergrund zu stehen sie kennen
vielleicht im griff der magic schon mal
gehört schreibt mal hin hier nötig
neudeck weist man von ihnen was dieser
begriff bedeutet ja genau genau ist ein
geburtshelfer kunst also sokratis
versteht sich nicht als derjenige der
den jetzt die wahrheit einpflanzt oder
den lange direkt die wahrheit sagt die
wahrheit so gibt also hier ist die
wahrheit hier ist die wahrheit und ihr
habt ja sie als wahrheit nicht als
gegenstand es ganz wichtig wahrheit darf
nicht vergeben ständig werden sondern
war hat als eine selbsterkenntnis also
die jeweiligen leute auch die da am
schalter schattenwand sitzen
sie müssen selbst irgendwie dazu kommen
man kann ihn aber dazu helfen sie müssen
die wahrheit selbst gebären also
wahrheit wird in diesem verständnis
nicht objektiv ist ish verstanden hier
ist die wahrheit
hier ist die falschheit sind ihr müsst
in einem prozess dynamisch selbst die
wahrheit hervorbringen ihr müsst sie
authentisch selbst am eigenen leibe
gewissermaßen erfahren wie man sagen
könnte ihm der vergleich der geburt das
hatten sie sich auch noch gemeldet
den nächsten teil und hat es damit auf
der ganzen welt auch genau welche
methode müssen wir nochmal frische
da kommen noch drauf genau genau genau
ich habe ja noch so eine übersichtskarte
der kammer am ende drauf als es gibt
drei gleichnisse höhlengleichnis sonst
gleich ins linien gleichnis und die halt
handel letztendlich von denselben dingen
oder selben problemen
man kann das aufeinander projizieren und
das ist dieser versuch dieser grafik da
komme jetzt am ende noch mal drauf
ich wollte es nun mal ganz kurz hier
auflegen gegessen aber nochmal zurück
also sehen es gibt ganz verschiedene
gleiches ebenen wir müssen schauen was
entspricht jetzt war es gehe jetzt noch
mal zurück zu diesem gleichnis haben sie
noch was zum höhengleich ist also
wichtiger punkt man ist befreit sie
hatten sich noch melden
[Musik]
ein guter punkt genau
sie sind nicht von derselben art wie die
schatten und eigentlich müssten sie
jetzt auf die idee kommen wir sind
körper also die schatten sind nur
zweidimensional und wir sind auch
dreidimensional müsste man sehen können
hmm
guter punkt offensichtlich sind diese
leute so verblendet nach diesem gleiches
dass sie sich darüber keine gedanken
machen also sie unterscheiden sich
gewissermaßen der punkt den sie bringen
die menschen vor der mauer unterscheiden
sich selbst nicht von den dingen die sie
sehen sie sehen die einfach ohne darauf
zu reflektieren dass sie von den dingen
eigentlich von diesen schatten bildern
unterschieden sind diese unterscheidung
dieses selbstbewusstsein findet ihr
offensichtlich nicht statt
könnte man sagen es hat eben erst die
sich gemeldet
ja
[Musik]
ja ja jetzt ist es eben nur so dass hier
doch hier wenn eine entfesselt wäre der
dritte sein
wenn einer entfesselt wäre und gezwungen
würde zugleich aufzustehen
das ist
ja ich denke dass es letztendlich eine
ganz ähnliche struktur aber das
entscheidende scheint mir zu sein dass
es von außen kommen sie sagen es muss
ein ereignis sein das liegt nicht in
meiner macht genauso kann auch jemanden
kommen um mich ihn fest
es muss irgendwas passieren was
außerhalb von mir liegt in diesem
gleichnis setting
aber diese umstände wären dann auch so
zwingend das meinen sie wären so zwingen
dass man gar nicht mehr anders kann
insofern würde ich sagen ihr beispiel
könnte man auch so in diesem sinne
interpretieren aber es eben wichtig wie
der kommilitone gesagt hat dass es
irgendwie ein moment des zwanges ist und
dass es nicht so ganz aus einem selbst
kommen sondern es gibt gewisse umstände
die das herausfordern
genau das ist was äußeres und das glaube
ich ganz wichtig jetzt ist sie nur und
anziehen
wir kommen noch auf die ideen genau das
so weit sind wir noch gar nicht wissen
nicht ganz hoch gestiegen sie hatten sie
noch gemeint
daneben
ja als ich interpretiere das über diesen
aufstieg jetzt über die melodik nach
sokratis also ganz innerhalb des
platonischen systems nun man braucht so
eine anleitung aber muss irgendwie
selbst haben jetzt endlich die idee
schauen muss selbst die wahrheit sehen
dazu man kann aber etwas dahin gebracht
werden von außen zu unterstützen
es gibt dann sicherlich im gesamten
christentum in der auch in verschiedenen
kulturen verschiedene interpretationen
dieses gleichnis das ist ja so zentral
zum beispiel könnte man auch jesus die
figur jesu damit in verbindung bringen
dieses gleichnis einfach von seiner
mutter folgt so grundsätzlich und so
entscheidend dass jede große religion
daraus gewinn ziehen kann
das würde ich ganz offen halten ich
glaube aber dass man das wenn man es im
eigentlichen sinne interpretieren soll
wenn das überhaupt geht dass man das
dann auf sokrates beziehen müsste das
scheint mir diese diese orientierungs
figur
würde ich auch so gc nach meinem wissen
ja es gibt da immer wieder so
transzendent im moment wo man kann es
ziemlich handfest sagen da kommt jemand
der sokratis auf der agora die menschen
auf dem in athen die wandelnde auf dem
marktplatz und sind in ihrer
schattenwelt verstrickt die haben da nur
meinungen die glauben jenes dieses und
dann kommt plötzlich eine und fragt sich
was ist eigentlich wahrheit wichtig so
könnte man es sagen richtig aber die
frage ist dann halt immer was ist so ein
dämon was ist das wird ganz schwierig
wenn man es einfach jetzt auf die
sachlage bezieht das sind menschen auf
dem marktplatz in athen und die haben
bestimmte vorgefertigte meinungen das
ist doch nur meinungen und ist es kein
wissen dass es keine begründung und
fragt zog hatte sie das ist nicht die
tugend und dann kommen die ganz schön
schwitzen und so tat es ab den leuten
nicht was die tugend ist sondern fragt
immer weiter fragt er fragt er fragen
also das ist wieder dieses verhältnis
zur wahrheit so hat er sagt nicht hier
ist die wahrheit stellt sich hin da
schaut sie an sondern er sagt was glaubt
ihr was die wahrheit ist dann sagen die
das und dann führt sokrates die
jeweiligen gesprächspartner in
widersprüche er zeigt dass ihre
ansichten bei licht besehen wenn man sie
durch denkt in widersprüche für und dann
fragte weiter erfahren immer weiter
weiter weiter bis ganz am ende
vielleicht der gesprächspartner auf die
richtige lösung kommt aber nicht selten
ist es so dass der dialog sind ja immer
dialogische geschehnisse bei platon dass
der dialog apolitisch endet apolitisch
heißt ohne eine lösung aussichtslos
endet das ist die situation genau haben
sich mehrere ganz hinten erstmal und
dann zielgenau
ein guter punkt weil ich gehe noch mal
hier ganz kurz nach vorne muss man
wieder kurz nach vorne springen hier
wenn sie nochmal dieses bild sich hier
anschauen
dann bemerkten sie da gibt es eine
struktur analogie also wir haben jetzt
hier zwar keine schattenbild aber der
mensch wirft einen schatten und hier ist
die sonne hier oben die menschenwürde
hier im schatten hinwerfen und dieses
verhältnis sonne mensch schatten ist
dasselbe verhältnis von der struktur her
die feier gegenstand schatten in der
höhle und jetzt könnte man sich fragen
ja vielleicht geht es nochmal eine stufe
höher
dass letztendlich die sonne eigentlich
auch nur so ein feuer zweiter stufe ist
und gibt es eigentlich noch ein höheres
licht der wahrheit von dem letztendlich
dann die dinge hier unten auch nur
schatten sind ja warum sollte es da
aufführen das fragen sie sich
genau das ist eine offene frage warum
hört da gerade auf das ist jetzt
natürlich noch wir sind noch in der
metaphorik der sonne und wirst du nicht
im eigentlichen bereich wir reden jetzt
nur metaphorisch und im sonnen gleichnis
als höhengleiche es im song gleichnis
vor allem linie gleich ist bringt dann
platon der begriff der idee als er
wendet dieses gleichnis konkret auf
begriffliche strukturen an aber auch da
könnte man sich dann irgendwie
vielleicht fragen gibt sich noch eine
höhere stufe aber sie haben recht im
sinne dieses gleichnis es hier geht ist
nicht unbedingt notwendig ersichtlich
dass es da aufhören müsste das könnte
auch weitergehen dass wir dann so
infinite regress immer weitere
begründung strukturen die höhe
gestaffelt sind
jetzt hatten sie sich gemeldet
entschuldigung habs grad akkus
inneres meinen sie jetzt in der höhle
und äußeres oben ach so ja
ja genau wir müssen einfach noch mal in
denen also in den text schauen und jetzt
in guter punkt jetzt achten sie mal ein
bisschen auf die metaphorik sich am
mittag mit metaphern verwendet er
schauen sie mal hier hier heilung was
ist eine metapher aus welchem bereich
kommt heim medizinisch also die leute
sind vielleicht sogar krank die müssen
geheilt werden so hat es ist der arzt
gibt es auch immer wieder solche
ansichten von sokrates also heilung also
da ist irgendwas nicht gesund das muss
geheilt werden und hier wenn eine
entfesselt wäre und gezwungen würde sind
alles passive konstruktionen entfesselt
gezwungen würde dass das geschieht ihm
von außen einfach wenn sie nur auf der
waldebene sich das anschauen das sind
passiv passiv konstruktion wird gezogen
dass man den zwang der systeme so
verspürt dass man
ok dann könnte man sich vielleicht zu
einigen gleich dass es das dagegen
widerstand angekämpft werden muss es
muss gegen inneren widerstand angekämpft
werden von dem subjekt selbst das
verhält sich zu sich selbst
aber es gibt ein widerstand der
überwunden werden muss sei es dass er
durch extrem äußeren antrieb überwunden
wird oder dass vielleicht auch so eine
reflexion stattfindet die sich davon
unterscheidet aber dann wäre es und in
eine innere äußerlichkeit sagen es wäre
eine innere differenz im subjekt selbst
dass das subjekt sich selbst äußerlich
wird und auf sich selbst und seinen
widerstand an seine schatten behaftet
reflektieren
ja wenn sich nochmal dieses bild
anschauen mit der schattenwelt die sind
doch da wirklich wie im kinosessel die
sitzen da ganz bequem da läuft so ein
toller streifen warum sollte ich jetzt
aufstehen und es genau genau wer wäre
nicht langweilig die wäre ganz
interessant das ist diese klar die
metaphorik ist die der film ist so
interessant wir würden die aufstehen wir
würden da unser ganzes leben im kino
sitzen wir wieder kompakt korn und
getränke und so weiter und so fort aber
wir würden das sitzenbleiben
das glaube ich das bild sie noch und
dann müssen wir weitergehen
also wunderbar ist es wunderbar wenn man
hier verschiedene ansichten hat genau so
muss es sein
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal weiter was
jetzt weiter im text kommt wir haben die
probleme genau wir haben die probleme
jetzt alle gesehen und ich möchte jetzt
einfach ein bisschen weitergehen und
achten sie noch ein bisschen hier auf
die metaphorik die metaphorik das
scheint hier ganz zentrales haben jetzt
gehen wir mal über zum sonne gleichnis
hier vor die augen sprach ich als ich so
hart es weißt du wohl wenn sie eine
nicht auf solche dinge richtet sie
finden hier unten die stelle das ist 85
habe es ein paar exzerpte genommen die
dinge richtet auf deren oberfläche das
tageslicht fällt und auf die nächtlichen
schimmer
so sind sie blöde die augen und schon
beinahe blind als ob keine reine
sehkraft in ihnen wäre wenn aber denk
ich auf das was die sonne bescheint dann
sehen sie deutlich und es zeigt sich
dass sind eben diesen augen die sehkraft
wohnt ebenso nun und jetzt kommt der
vergleich ebenso nun betrachtet dasselbe
auch an der seele wenn sie sich auf das
heftet woran wahrheit und das seien die
glänzt sowie merck und erkennt sie ist
und es zeigt sich dass die vernunft hat
wenn aber auch dass mit finsternis
gemischte das entstehende und vergehen
so meint sie nur so meint sie nur und
ihr gesicht verdunkelt sich so dass sie
ihre vorstellung bald so weit so herum
wirft gab es mit allen also ball kommt
daher und wiederum aussieht als ob sie
keine vernunft hätte und jetzt achten
sie mal darauf wieder mit erfolg spricht
oblaten von der wahrheit
es richtig aber jetzt achten sie noch
ein bisschen auf die metaphorik also
welche bildsprache benutzt plattform
entspricht jetzt ja nicht von kohärenz
spricht er von korrespondenz lexus hier
achten sie mal was sind die metaphern
genau also wir hatten gesagt es gibt
auch so ein evidenz theorie wissen sie
noch nach dem was ich in der ersten
sitzung gesagt hatte bei welchem
philosophen diese evidenz theorie
besonders auftritt descartes genau das
hat klar und das ding dieses korridors
evidenz dieses evidenz erlebnis
descartes spricht auch vom licht der
vernunft als hat sowas von evidenz
ja genau das sind gute erkenntnis gute
bemerkung wir sehen ist es einerseits
hat etwas von evidenz theorie es hat
auch noch was von etwas anderem von
einer anderen theorie war es wenn sie
mal schauen hier wenn sie mal schauen
hier woran wahrheit und das seien
begrenzt auf das heftet woran wahrheit
und das eindecken ist inwiefern
genau genau wo könnte vielleicht aus
santo logische theorie die dinge selbst
sind war es ganz schwierig sie
erscheinen in bestimmten licht sie
glänzen und das glänzen ist jetzt ja
nicht unbedingt dem ding nur eigens
sondern wenn wir das ding in den
schatten stellen
denken sie also goldklumpen und den
schatten stellen und dann glänzt er
nicht mehr
dann wären wir denn es kommt darauf an
dass die sonne auf den gegenstand fällt
das heißt es ist wohl doch eher nicht
nur ökologische theorie da sagt die die
mir selbst sind war sondern sie wir
erkennen die dinge nur dann in unserem
verhältnis wenn wir sie ausrichten an
der sonne wenn wir die dinge in der
sonne
vorliegend finden wenn das nicht drauf
es geht also wieder um so eine
perspektive auf das ganze die
perspektive kann richtig wahr oder
falsch seien
es scheint aber auch nicht nur und
logische theorie zu sein
genau
es kommt ist spielt eine gewisse
relation mehr ohne es geht um relation
genau deswegen würde ich jetzt auch
nicht sagen dass es einen theologischen
theorie ist die er vertritt eine
ökologische valtteri insofern die dinge
selbst wahr sind oder falsch sondern er
sagt ja hier woran wahrheit unter seien
die glänzt und ich möchte mal den blick
darauf lenken auf die metaphorik können
sie da noch ein bisschen was dazu sagen
was für eine bildersprache verwendet
platon sie haben jetzt gesagt evidenz
das kann man noch ein bisschen
allgemeiner sei wieder im sitzen
spezialfall davon geredet er denn hier
oder anders gefragt welcher sinn ist
metaphorisch sicher der menschlichen
sinnesorgane ist vor allem relevant für
wahrheit genau das sehen also ganz stark
visuelle metaphern das auge das ist ganz
wichtig das geht so weit dass selbst der
begriff des wissens in griechischem
visuelle metapher ist also weiß jemand
von ihnen was wissen auf griechisch
heißt ja wissen ja das ist die weisheit
ja also wissen jetzt im sinne des der
tätigkeit ist denn da heißt es ich
schaut mal hin
und das heißt eigentlich nur wenn man es
jetzt genau untersucht gesehen haben
also wissen vom wort von der wort
geschichte griechischen helden heißt
gesehen haben also ich habe gesehen und
deswegen weiß ich weiß jemand von ihnen
wie man das nennt
in der sprachwissenschaft zu einwerbung
was eigentlich von der struktur her von
tempus eigentlich eine
vergangenheitsform ist aber eine
präsenten bedeutung hat ich weiß jetzt
sehr präsent sein präsent das ist ein
präteritum presse ein präteritum
bressons als ein verb was präsent ische
bedeutung hat aber eigentlich genau
besehen der vergangenheitsform ich weiß
ich weiß deswegen weil ich gesehen habe
weil es mal gesehen habe und erinnerung
behalten habe weiß ich jetzt
also man sieht im griechischen wissen
und wahrheit sind ganz eng verbunden mit
visuellen tätigkeit auch hier wenn sie
mal schauen
es geht hier glänzen glänzen glänzend
alles sind alles qualitäten die man
virtuell visuell wahrnimmt immer so was
wie schön augen die augen also in der
metaphorik sehr sehr visuell und das
kann uns jetzt ein anhaltspunkt dafür
geben was für eine wahrheits theorie
beratung vertrieb wir lesen einfach mal
weiter
dieses also was dem erkennbaren den
dingen in der welt muss man sagen
wahrheit mitteilen dass jetzt die ganz
zentralen stelle und dem erkennenden das
vermögen her gibt zu erkennen sage sei
die idee des guten
aber wie sieht der erkenntnis und der
wahrheit als welche erkannt wird ursache
zwar ist so wirst du doch so schön auch
diese beide sind
erkenntnis und wahrheit doch nur wenn du
dir jenes als ein anderes und noch
schöneres als beide denkst richtig
denken die kenntnisse und wahrheit sowie
dort licht und gesicht für sollen artig
zu halten zwar recht war für die sonne
selbst aber nicht recht so ist auch hier
so ist auch hier diese beiden für
gutartig zu halten zwar recht für das
gute selber aber gleich viel welches von
beiden anzusehen nicht recht so noch
höher ist die beschaffenheit des guten
zu schätzen
wie hat man da so verschieden dass es
jetzt etwas sehr sehr verschachtelt
formuliert wir mal den ersten satz
also es kommt jedenfalls von außen
irgendwie also ist nichts was dem ding
selbst inne wohnt das glaube ich ganz
wichtig das hatten sie auch schon gesagt
dass es so eine relation
aber schauen sie mal den ersten satz an
dieses also was den erkennbaren wahrheit
mitteilt und dem erkennen das vermögen
hergibt
das müssen wir jetzt mal uns vielleicht
grafisch veranschaulicht wie könnte man
sich diese dieses verhältnis denken
wie ist die relation in der zweiten
reihe
genau wir haben also wir haben das
zusammen wir haben den erkennenden oder
die erkennende erkenntnis subjekt wir
haben den gegenstand oder die erkenntnis
gegenstand
und was kommt jetzt noch ein spiel ist
es jetzt so dass wahrheit nur im
verhältnis des erkenntnisses objekt zum
gegenstand gesteht was wäre das für eine
theorie wenn ich sagen würde die
wahrheit ist die relation das erkennen
des objekts zum erkennen den gegenstand
die irgendwie richtig ist die angemessen
ist jetzt habe ich schon fast fach also
wenn wir jetzt sagen nur diese relation
hier sah man diese horizontale das
kennen das objekt das sagt irgendetwas
das denkt irgendetwas und im sagen
denken kennen meinen wie auch immer in
kognitiven einstellungen wird das der
sache die in wirklichkeit dingen gerecht
dass wenn ihr korrespondenz zu der
wahrheit
jetzt hat aber platon wie sie richtig
gesagt haben noch eine weitere dimension
dem spiel für die wahrheit und wie kann
ich die jetzt hier in dieses bild
bringen
also soll ich jetzt dann zwei
runtermachen und da auch das müssen wir
uns noch schauen was wieder hin
schreiben genau also das wäre jetzt soll
ich schon mal hier korrespondenz
hinschreiben es schadet da nichts mehr
es ist ja damit jetzt nicht gesagt dass
es eine korrespondenz theorie sei gibt
es eine korrespondenz wir müssen uns
jetzt fragen wie genau die idee des
guten die natürlich der sonne entspricht
das ist das ein gleichnis entspricht der
soll er bleibt jetzt hier ist hat die
diese metapher sagt diese sonnenlicht
können sie mal dieser metapher noch ein
bisschen aus buchstabieren wie was genau
macht die sonne als erstmal hier haben
wir jetzt das ding der welt hier haben
wir die menschen und her mal die sonne
was macht die sonne im prozess geht es
hier in der sich um die analogie von
seen von wahrnehmen dass das visuelle
die visuelle metaphorik und von erkennen
das ist eine mentale angelegenheit
wartung analogie ziert das wahrnehmen
das erkennen das sinnliche mit dem
geistig er würde sagen dass geistige ist
eine höhere art von sinnlichkeit ein
besonderes sind
richtig aber wenn sie jetzt noch bei dem
licht bleiben was macht denn das
sonnenlicht genau mit bezug auf diese
diese zwei pole hier einfach noch ein
bisschen genauer beschreiben sie habe
schon richtig gesagt was macht das licht
einfach was für was ist es gut wenn sie
noch mal daran legen hier ist ja noch
ein auge hier ist dennoch dieses auge
das auge
ach so könnte man sich denken sie haben
sich gemeldet
das meinten sie ja auch ne genau kann
man das noch ein bisschen weiter
ausbauen ist völlig richtig
haben sie sich noch gemeldet ja genau
ist alles richtig die sonne ist der
grund irgendwie der grund für die
erkenntnis wir müssen jetzt genauer
schauen wie die sonne der grund oder die
idee des guten auch der grund genau ist
grund kann man in verschiedenen hinsicht
verstehen kann sein dass die kausal
grund kann sagen es ist die erkenntnis
grund man kann sagen dass der science
grund wir müssen ja noch genauer
nachschauen ja genau wie soll sonst
schafft so eine rahmen gewissermaßen zu
wechseln öffnet einen raum innerhalb
dessen überhaupt erst erkannt werden
kann man sagen die bedingung der
möglichkeit vielleicht ein bisschen
transzendentale damit überhaupt
orientierung möglich ist brauchen wir
die sonne der sonnenlicht fällt auf den
gegenstand und macht dadurch den
gegenstand für das auge sichtbar und
dadurch kann sie das auge auf den
gegenstand richten
auch ein guter punkt also sie sagen so
das sonnenlicht fällt auf den gegenstand
der gegenstand glänzt sagt bathen und
glänzt so dass von dort das licht
zurückgespiegelt wird meine augen so
könnte man sich das denken
ja
das ein guter vergleich der sagt einmal
ist es der sichtbare raum das sichtfeld
und einmal ist es der logische raum der
raum dessen was war da falsch sein kann
könnte man sagen was wahrheit werte
tragen kann ja
ja
also guter punkt sie sagen jetzt es gibt
auch noch irgendwie anhaltspunkte vorne
kohärenz theorie und jetzt müssen wir
schauen wo genau wird die kohärenz
theorie reinbekommen ich denke das ist
ganz klar die karenz theorie wird
irgendwie in diesem verhältnis also im
vertikalen hier anzusiedeln zahlen wir
haben also zwei achsen eine horizontale
achse die es eher korrespondenz und
vielleicht haben wir hier auf dieser
vertikalen achse noch anhaltspunkte für
eine kohärenz theorien
das müssen wir uns aber noch schauen
also es geht erstmal um diese dinge
genau ist es erstmal hier ausgerichtet
auf diese dinge
man könnte sich jetzt auch fragen nach
dem was sie gesagt haben ist vielleicht
auch eine korrespondenz zwischen
erkenntnis gegenstand und idee des guten
gegeben
oder ist es eher im sinne der kohärenz
denken das könnte man sich auch fahren
ja
sieht man ja auch werden
um genau gebraucht und führt diese auch
ja sie haben völlig recht es kommt noch
eine kohärenz theoretische dimension ins
spiel und wir müssen jetzt weiter lesen
und dann am ende schauen wo die genau
rein passt also hier haben wir jetzt
noch mal unser dreieck nicht dieses also
was dem erkennbaren wahrheit vermittelt
das ist der gegenstand und dem erkennen
das vermögen hergibt dass das erkenntnis
objektes ins auge sage sei die idee des
guten das ist praktisch jetzt dass das
gibt das vermögen und es teilt wahrheit
mit
es macht die dinge glänzend jetzt
natürlich auch etwas sehr vage
formuliert wahrheit mittag also die idee
des guten ist sagte dann sagt er weiter
ursache ursache der erkenntnis und der
wahrheit in die des guten das ursache
der erkenntnis und der wahrheit ist ein
bisschen schwierig jetzt zu verstehen
als erkenntnis und wahrheit dass er
jetzt wahrheit dass er erkenntnis die
sind hier nur auf dieser ebene
angesiedelt deswegen ist hier das
argument diesem zitat muss das wenige
was der grund von erkenntnissen von
wahrheit ist das muss noch viel höher
sein
das ist dann hier die idee des guten das
hier nie was der grund einer sache ist
steht natürlich über der sache
wir lesen mal weitergelesen weiter
möchte mal jemand von ihnen lesen
zur abwechslung wollen sie vielleicht
ja
das jetzt spannend jetzt kommt eine neue
dimension in spielen wie kann man jetzt
in diesem zitat dieses verhältnis von
ihr könnt es auch ganz einfach so machen
mit geben da im dreieck buchstaben das
ist a das ist und das ist er
wie ist das verhältnis von abe strecke
aber in diesem text nähe bestimmt also
wie kann ich diese relation von a zu b
nach diesem zitat hier noch ein bisschen
besser beschreiben
77 sagen kausal ursache was sagt er
genau
genau das sein das wesen hat also sage
ich es richtig weh hat seinen sinn und
wesen von ah stimmt es so und wie kann
man ja
genau das ist auch richtig das betrifft
auch dieses verhältnis von a und b der
kreis wäre dann die idee haben sich
schon meine natur einen perfekten kreis
gesehen ich nicht kann es in der natur
ein perfekten kreis geben ich glaube
auch nicht wenn man es immer weiter
herunter bricht ins detail kommen jetzt
immer kleineren teilchen und wir werden
nie in der natur unendliche als die
frage ob sich conti nun gibt oder ob die
natur diskret ist das halt die frage der
mathematik ist es ganz einfach da ist
ein kreis einfach eine unendlich große
anzahl von punkten die von einem anderen
punkt demselben abstand tat die sich
darum gruppieren wo der abstand immer
derselbe ist und sie merken wenn wir
einen kreis mathematisch beschreiben
das haben sie auch gemacht in der
oberstufe in dieser analytische
geometrie
da können sie denn den kreis einfach
durch so eine begleichung formulieren
und da haben sie nichts mehr sinnliches
treten also nichts mehr empirisches da
haben sie keinen keine linie haben sie
einfach nur ein verhältnis sehr
komplexes verhältnis definieren und klar
dann stellt sich so die idee vor die
idee ist so wie man in der mathematik
sind kreis definiert durch verhältnisse
so ist die idee zu denken also ist nach
platon sind der platten ideen zu denken
und die wirklichen dinge in der welt sie
eine konkrete gerade ist also ein kreis
den ich jetzt hier zeichne oder ein
kreis die mir sonst irgendwie vorkommen
in der natur aber genauso ein baum sagt
platon ein baum ist nur deswegen ein
baum oder genauer gesagt kann auch nur
deswegen als baum erkannt werden weil
der anteil hat sagt daten an der idee
des baumes
also es geht letztendlich immer darum
warum kann ich etwas erkennen
das ist die erkenntnis grund die frage
nach dem erkenntnis grund warum kann ich
jetzt den kreis als kreis erkennen
wodurch kreise verschieden groß sein
können
es gibt kreise mit fünf zentimetern
durchmesser es gibt kreise mit 20
zentimeter durchmesser mit fünf
kilometer durchmesser wieso kann ich
diese verschiedenen großen
als kreise erkennen es hat einen wegen
der abstrakte idee des kreises die
einfach so lautet der selbe gegenstand
von einem punkt das kann jetzt der
abstand er selber abstand von einen
punkt der abstand kann jetzt einen
solchen betrag oder einen solchen betrag
haben darauf kommt sich an das ist
dieselbe struktur
das ist also jetzt die erkenntnis grund
genauso warum kann ich erkennen dass das
ein baum ist und dass das was daneben
steht auch ein baum ist seit platon
wegen der idee des baumes ist erkenntnis
kommen daran geht aber noch weiter sagt
es ist nicht nur so dass ich wegen die
idee einer gewissen idee jetzt etwas als
etwas erkennen sondern dasjenige was ich
erkennen ist auch nur deswegen in der
welt weil es an der idee teil hat also
die idee ist nicht nur der erkenntnis
grund der jeweiligen dinge sondern auch
der science grundbedingung ja ganz
er würde sagen die welt hängt davon ab
dass sie in bezug auf weist zu der idee
zu den jeweiligen wir reden jetzt hier
noch mit anderen ideen als es gibt hier
verschiedene anträge den noch darunter
die d1 d2 also sollte hier seien die
zwei das noch nicht die idee des guten
verschiedene ideen des baumes idee dass
das crysis und dasjenige was hier in der
welt vorkommt ist nur deswegen weil es
irgendwie wenn wir sagen dass b1 ein
beliebiger gegenstand b2 weil diese hier
anteil haben an der jeweiligen moment
ich muss das falsch das war falsch das
muss b 1
weil der jeweilige gegenstand an der
entsprechende detail hat deswegen
existierte und deswegen kann er auch
erkannt werden
darüber wölbt sich dann aber noch die
idee des guten die kommt nochmal oben
drauf und das müssen jetzt genau klären
also die ideen die abstrakte gebilde
sind sowohl der erkenntnis grund sind
der grund dafür dass wir die dinge
erkennen weil sie uns den begriff geben
die definition was ist ein baum ganz
abstrakt das ist ein kreis begrifflich
und weil sie aber auch und das ist die
stärkere these von platon im falle des
baumes weil sie die existenz des baumes
erst ermöglichen
so weit würden wir häufig nicht gehen
wir würden sagen begriffe wie wir
begriffe haben also ideen kann man sagen
ein begriff wir sagen wir haben den
begriff des baumes und wir haben wir den
begriff des baumes gewonnen wenn sie
jetzt fragen wie ist das verhältnis von
baum und begriff des baums was würden
sie sagen mal kurz ins plenum
wie ist das verhältnis von begriffen
gegenstand sie haben bäume 1000 und sie
haben begriffe den begriff des baumes
was hängt von was ab sind nur die bäume
deswegen draußen sichtbar oder
existieren sie auch nur weil wir den
begriff des baumes haben oder kommen
erst die bäume und dann beginnt die
begriffe was würden sie sagen